тривога на блокпості
хороший автомобіль на мага це
прорватися до рису гаража алан про проте
жартома нейтралізує зазвичай так санвузлах
вже на вигляд бувало це насправді
добровольці з любліну нападали quit
hanowa кордону польші 30 c2 хіба на
місяць багату з учасників у
парамілітарних ви загону років ви досягли
20 річкового віку
і хоча он і стріляють полотно і ми на
бою ми їх не на світ і телком серйозніше
теж ущільнивши паства не той факт, що
польша не прибуває б спати і
призначаєш що одного дня
ціни majoris кузмин і ти вся Україна
тему найкраще стрибаючи з україною 100-го
моменту як на сході україни зриваючи
криваве протистояння
кіль пензлем хоче про і треба сюди загону
відбулося стригти і три сотні людей
тоді кілька щеня 30 ти у так звання
територіальний самооборону люблінського
воєводства
їх ним провідником є ​​даміан туди
професор стратегії то bespeco
університету Любліно
ти че тут вид буваєте а для нього ван
гра такі загони кожен ген може штати
у природі в раз і учи кованого нападу
він скафе д'алема
польша ще добра пом'ята та 1939 to die у
нас так уже було союзники червона ми за
вийшла вона 17 коли мечами союзників
речі спи дроселі польської армії
розтушовано на заході України і є
розміщених просто не захоплення днів до си
за інерцією ідею доктрина не наш ворог
знаходиться на заході червоним же бат уроці ми
нула її в роті перевести з підрозділи
нас хіт польші
жінка схід ми проїжджаємо 80 кілометрів
дали нас хіт тут польща чоловікові з україною
біля залу на обличчя знову і за зовнішній кордон
з на верхову чіпа самотнього патруля то
про кордонного посту створюється
ні чим на помітну меце звісткою наша
річка бух розділяє we країни
я саджу china те що нато різновид початку
щури в Україні
посилання у свою злочинністю поштою
наслідному кордоні дасин і бавиться
тваринного педро диллона того рядком і
основі в любліні через ти ж жива і
т.п. завищеними на виробляючи белль
частина тут знаючи прометею самооборону
і заради це чоловік кований так так я вже
проточу все добре за нинішнього
пристойна втеча обираються на 1000
буваєте в Україні з зовсім не гоилися
мрія я хочу знати історію очевидно що
росія миколи була дружною україною і
ніхто не може віддавати перевагу кому на
дієтами
алани можна передавати ася пам'яті 3 бар
адже теж у цю ситуацію але
можна вимикати енергії кроку сценаріїв
нам з потрібну
віджав баскова служба була оповідь про wanna
наша армія наявності лаше 70000 вояки
також розірви стояв його наймаєте вони
доброго оружня не
вони на помилковому вишку вираз про вину
на донбасі даміан дудос клаву собою сто
проти розум 10 днів у угорців долею боях
на боті українських добровольців що
боровся проти проросійських
сепаратистів
українці столи для нього прикладом тугий
як треба саму організовують та ся тазах
та штати батьківщину
сигнал для бутику і держави не можна
надути синюватий потрібні вас тіла крем
гру водянка прошу шкіра ти че з
оборонятися їм захищати та владно
україну і хочу людина тіло хоче щось у
буде кумар азії знає і можна vista
самооборона в любліні не за баранина
алла фінансується без самостійно
допомогою по жертв у пошуку ми
міністерстві оборони пукін і поспішає
спить проти ти з добровольцями даміан
дудочку дівається що дана хірша по
сценарію nadejda його пропонуємо нема ось
ці брат і вчитель стражник боях червоне
покладаючи на волю ви тортуру
провини хочеш я хочу ти про наш світ to
die with u сяду провини я не хочу розпущена
танула я захочу but i dunno та готовий до
тому ж може бути показаний плавати там
вбити і самооборони не хоче поліпшити
осідала в польську армію таві дають
парової пари militare не підготуйте
відповіди всіх одна кого геть і не хочуть
виду [ __ ] ти себе види чайних вже ти базу
не форми
у своєму рідному коханому